Vsauce Kevin here spit out your gum put
down that toad and follow a rainbow to
the Wishing Well swallow chewing gum
doesn't stay in your stomach for seven
years since your teeth don't break down
gum like food fears arose that stomachs
had similar trouble processing it but it
really just passes through your system
like the outside fiber shell of corn
swallowing several pieces of gum a day
however could develop a bezoar
a hard mass that clogs the digestive
tract in severe cases surgery is needed
to remove this blockage and the
disimpaction procedure is described in a
medical journal as like a taffy pull
touching a toad will not give you warts
toads are covered in wart like bumps
that help them blend into their
environments but warts on humans are a
virus the problem was that no one before
1892 knew what a virus was so the
transmission of warts through toad
handling was a common explanation
methods for getting rid of warts often
involved rubbing something on them like
a bean pod piece of beef or your
mother's dish rag and then burying it
and as the item rotted away
so apparently went the wart in reality
warts can suddenly disappear on their
own due to the nature of the human
papilloma virus so many bizarre wart
remedies like dripping eel blood or
blowing on it nine times under the full
moon were believed to really work
tossing coins in water fountains and
ponds for good luck comes from the
tradition of wishing wells ancient
dramatic and Celtic people thought that
by offering gifts like pins or coins to
the water deities that lived in wells
they would be granted their wish which
often was about finding a sweetheart
and while the wishes may not have always
been granted pure silver and pure copper
coins tossed into wells may have been
making the water safer to drink silver
kills bacteria in water it's been used
as a water disinfecting agent on the
International Space Station and a 2012
study shows storing drinking water in
copper pots can also kill certain
harmful bacteria therefore Helga's wish
for a boyfriend
they have prevented her entire village
from getting diarrhea but silver and
copper coins are no gold according to
Irish folklore just visit the end of a
rainbow to find a pot of gold guarded by
a leprechaun unfortunately you can never
reach the end of a rainbow because
seeing a rainbow requires you to be a
distance away from it so that the
sunlight can refract off water droplets
and hit your eyes after Vikings invaded
Ireland around the 10th century they
left behind hordes of treasure which are
supposedly guarded by leprechauns to
prevent greedy humans from fighting over
it a metal detector recently uncovered
over a hundred silver and gold Viking
artifacts near the coast of the Irish
Sea so a bit of science and technology
were all that was needed to get those
lucky charms and as always ooh thanks
thanks for watching